now that we understand what we're
looking for the higgs boson and how it
interacts how you might produce it
we also understand the basic features of
particle accelerators and colliders and
detectors that will actually find the
things we're ready to go out and build
the machine that will actually find the
higgs boson what we now know as the
large hadron collider
except of course we're not nearly ready
to build it because no one has ever been
ready to build the large hadron collider
it's hard to emphasize exactly what kind
of undertaking we're talking about here
the lhc is the most complicated machine
ever built by human beings so by
construction
no one was ever trained to do it because
nothing like it had ever been done
before now this sounds a little trivial
of course the people who built the lhc
had built other particle accelerators
had been involved in the design but when
you build something of this scope and
magnitude there will always be
challenges that you hadn't quite
foreseen and these are the kinds of
challenges they don't train you to
deal with when you're a physics graduate
student getting your phd and writing
down feynman diagrams and calculating
the answers there's a lot of human
wisdom and ingenuity and gumption that
goes into actually achieving something
like this
so let's go back
to what we might think of as the
pre-history of the large hadron collider
and it really goes back to the 1980s it
was in 1984 that the first concentrated
working group got together and said what
kind of machine could we build that
ultimately led to building the lhc
now in the 1980s in the early 80s cern
had discovered the w boson and the z
boson in 1983
and then they won the nobel prize the
very next year in 1984. the nobel went
to carlo rubia who was the leader of an
experiment at cern called ua-1 who had
found the w and then the z soon
thereafter he shared the nobel by the
way with another physicist at cern named
simon vandermeer and vandermeer
interestingly didn't win the nobel for
discovering a new particle
he received it for inventing a technique
known as stochastic cooling remember
from last lecture we have these beams of
particles and the particles in the beam
are closely bunched together
but if you think about it all these
particles in any one bunch they're
either protons or antiprotons so in
other words they all have the same
electrical charge
and that means that every proton in the
bunch is repelling all the other protons
the bunches want to grow
so there's quite a technical
accomplishment in getting the bunches to
remain small and dense so you get many
many collisions that technique of
stochastic cooling invented by van der
meer made modern particle accelerators
possible
so after rubia found the w particle and
the z particle they were on to find the
next thing every particle physicist is
instantly looking for the next discovery
so in the early 1980s there were two
very obvious candidates there was the
higgs boson and there was the top quark
plus that of course we knew that there
was particle physics beyond the standard
model maybe there was supersymmetry or
something new and exotic
now eventually we found the top quark at
fermilab not at cern it was the tevatron
that finally found the top quark in 1995
but cern was definitely looking for it
and they definitely wanted to find the
higgs
when we talk about cern we're really
talking about a gigantic operation
cern is the european center for nuclear
research letters are in a different
order because it's originally in french
and these days most of the research is
particle physics not nuclear physics but
the organization was established back in
1954
it was part of rebuilding european
science after world war ii
right now there are 21 member states of
cern that is the actual states that
govern the operation by states we mean
countries of course so england france
germany and so forth but there are 70
countries that participate in one way or
another so countries like the us
russia india and japan are called
observer nations
they're will they're
welcome to work at cern and they do
they're certainly welcome to contribute
money but the 21 member states are the
ones who actually run the operation and
contribute most of the budget if you go
through that budget obviously building
something like the large hadron collider
costs a lot of money
but it works out to no more than about
two dollars per person per year for
people in the actual member states of
cern
one of the great things about cern is
that it is a model of international
cooperation many physicists who you will
talk to will say that if the united
nations worked together as well as cern
did we would have world peace you will
see israeli physicists working with
palestinian physicists we all want to
find the higgs boson and it's a big
complicated arrangement if you fly into
geneva on an airplane
chances are that about 1 in 16 people on
your flight are associated with cern one
way or the or another
so after rubia's experiment in the 1980s
to find the w boson and the z the next
thing that was already in the pipeline
for cern was what we already mentioned
something called the large electron
positron collider or lep
lep bran from 1989 to 2000 and it was
certainly looking for the higgs boson it
was colliding electrons and positrons it
created z bosons and w bosons at an
enormous rate
but look as they would they could not
quite find the higgs their limit the
heaviest mass that they could really
reach at lep was about
114 gev
now it turns out if you were around and
paying attention to particle physics in
the year 2000 you would have noticed
that there were hints
that there was a higgs boson at about
115 gev just beyond
the reach of lep
but we had to make a decision should we
shut down lep and start building the
large hadron collider or should we keep
pushing and maybe find the higgs there
at 1 15.
roughly speaking the cern management ran
lep for a few months past its due date
its expiration date i should say and
then they decided to finally turn it off
they did not find the higgs at 115 gev
so meanwhile of course the united states
was not sitting still we had the
tevatron at fermilab but we were
planning to build the superconducting
supercollider this would have reached 40
trillion electron volts 40 tev of energy
and the europeans said to themselves
if the u.s is building this giant hadron
collider there's no reason for us here
in europe to do that we don't have the
resources to build a 40 tev machine
but carlo rubia who is at that time a
professor at harvard said you know i
know these americans don't trust them
don't believe that they will actually do
this machine that they're planning on
and in fact he was right the ssc the
superconducting super collider was
cancelled by congress in 1993 it was a
very acrimonious debate some physicists
who were not particle physicists
actually argued against building it and
the sort of bad blood over that debate
still lingers in physics circles today
so because of that ruby argued that cern
should go ahead and design its own
hadron collider which we imaginatively
named the large hadron collider the lhc
it was a welsh physicist named lynn
evans who was picked in the 1980s to
head the project and he only stepped
down very very recently and i think it
was 2012 that he finally retired from
that job lynn evans was the person who
guided the lhc from conception to design
to building to ultimate operation that's
a job again they don't train you for it
in graduate school there is as much
politics involved as there is physics
you have to keep 21 member nations in
cern happy
and for example in the year 2001 it was
discovered that the lhc was about 20
over budget
now by standards of united states
particle physics and space and big
science projects 20 over budget is
nothing projects routinely go double the
budget but the europeans are a bit more
persnickety and evans was almost fired
when it was learned that he was 20 over
budget but he persevered he stuck
through it and ultimately he guided the
lhc to a successful completion
the target was 14 trillion electron
volts for their energy remember the sse
would have been 40 trillion but the lhc
was constrained because they were saving
money by building it inside the same
tunnel that lep had been built in the
lhc underground didn't have a tunnel
dedicated to it we took out lep from the
tunnel we put the lhc in
that means we knew what the size was we
knew what the maximum energy we could
reach was going to be it's going to be
14 tev that's still quite a bit higher
than the previous hadron collider at
cern the superconducting proton
anti-proton synchrotron that was less
than half of one trillion electron volts
so because we could build the lhc inside
obviously i'm using we in the very very
royal sense because cern could build the
lhc inside the pre-existing tunnel they
saved money they had a 27 kilometer ring
underground beneath the french swiss
border part of the lhc is in switzerland
part of it is in france it's a hundred
meters underground and if you're above
the lhc you could be in someone's living
room there are people who live right on
top of the lhc there are cow pastures
and so forth it's actually quite a
scenic arrangement if you go to visit
cern
but what you have to do is fill up that
tunnel 27 kilometers around with some of
the highest tech most expensive
equipment that human beings have ever
made
most of that length
consists of superconducting magnets to
collimate the beams to focus the beams
of protons to a very very tiny amount
and to steer them around the ring
remember we said that the actual
acceleration of the particles is done by
a radio frequency cavity but if you
think about this ring that is the lhc we
don't accelerate the protons all over
the ring there's one little segment they
go through and get accelerated the
entire rest of the ring is just
dedicated to steering and focusing the
protons
all told there's about
1600 superconducting magnets
linking together underneath that ring
27 tons each is how much each of those
magnets weighs it's quite a bit of
operation going on
now what you're doing inside these
magnets is you're steering beams of
protons and there are two beams you're
bringing the beams into collision if you
had
protons and anti-protons you could push
them in the same beam pipe because
they're going in opposite directions but
they're also oppositely charged but if
you have protons going both ways you
need two different beam pipes so in
every one of those magnets there's two
little tubes protons going one way more
protons going the other way inside the
tubes it is almost empty space because
you don't want the protons bumping into
the air the atmospheric pressure inside
these vacuum tubes is less than you
would feel if you were standing on the
surface of the moon
and of course they're also very very
cold because the magnets themselves are
superconducting
if you think about what a magnet is the
easiest way to make a magnet is just to
run an electric current through a wire
the problem is if you run a lot of
current the wire heats up and melts
the solution to that is to cool it down
so much that the wire becomes a
superconductor there is no more
electrical resistance and therefore you
can run as much current in it as you
want without heating it up
so the trick to making the lhc magnets
not heat up is to keep them very very
very cold that's when you get super
conductivity so the lhc magnets are less
than two degrees above absolute zero
they're literally colder than
interstellar space
through these magnets of course we're
zooming protons they're moving at a
speed these days of about
99.99999 percent the speed of light that
doesn't mean very much so therefore what
we care about is the energy
in the beam and that's where we're
aiming for this target of about 14
trillion electron volts total that means
that the protons going one way have
seven trillion electron volts each and
going the other way you also have seven
and you bump into each other
there's about 600 trillion protons in
the beams at any one moment of time that
sounds like a lot 600 trillion
but one gram of protons has
over a trillion trillion protons so
really there's not a lot of protons by
weight in the in the lac beam at any one
moment these are all collimated to a
very thin pencil beam when i say pencil
that's uh exaggerating the size the
actual size of the beam is about two
thousandths of a centimeter across
you bring these two beams into collision
and you get literally about a billion
collisions per second every one time
that a bunch crosses you get tens of
collisions
now obviously this gives you a lot of
data as we've already discussed you have
to throw away a lot of the data through
a trigger but even once you've thrown
away all but one in a million events
you're still left with about 30
petabytes of data every year
a peta
is a million billion so a petabyte is a
million billion bytes compared to
gigabytes
terabytes or a thousand gigabytes a
petabyte is a thousand terabytes so 30
petabytes a year are created at the lhc
before the lhc came online the world's
largest database was the world data
center for climate
six petabytes total every year at the
lhc we make five times the biggest
amount of database that we've ever had
here on earth before that
but all of these gigantic numbers come
from one tiny little proton source which
is basically a flask of hydrogen that
looks kind of like a fire extinguisher
it's a little tiny thing but it has many
many many hydrogen atoms in it you strip
off the electrons from the hydrogen
atoms then you get protons you send them
around the beam it's very nice and
reassuring to think that even this
gigantic machine has the humble
beginnings in this little canister full
of hydrogen
once we have our protons moving around
the ring in both directions at certain
points around the ring we're going to
bring those beams of protons into
collision and that's where we want to
build a detector which will watch what
happens when the individual particles
smash together
at the lhc there are four large
detectors there are several smaller ones
but four whopping big detectors and of
those four two of them are general
purpose they look for everything and two
of them are more specialized the general
purpose ones are called atlas and cms
atlas is the boring acronym namely a
toroidal lhc apparatus
if you've seen pictures from the lhc
there's a very good chance you've seen a
picture of atlas it looks like a piece
of alien technology there were great
pictures taken before it was completed
and you see this gigantic thing
all the lac detectors are huge on a
human scale atlas is 25 meters across
but 46 meters long half of a football
field and it weighs 7 000 tons if you're
standing next to atlas it's very
difficult to see you because you're
swamped by the technology
and the way something like atlas works
is it's a collaboration many people from
many different countries over three
thousand physicists are associated with
atlas but some of someone needs to be
the boss so they take turns electing
what is called a spokesperson for the
collaboration when the whole
collaboration publishes a paper in a
scientific journal all three thousand
members are authors of that paper but
it's the spokespeople who get the nice
job of giving the seminars when you
discover the higgs boson or something
like that
for atlas the original spokesperson was
peter yenni from germany he was followed
by fabiola giannatti from italy and she
was fortunate enough to be the
spokesperson when they got to give these
seminars announcing the higgs discovery
and today a british physicist dave
charlton is leader of atlas
the other major general purpose
experiment at the lhc is called cms for
compact muon solenoid of course cms is
only compact when you compare it to
atlas it is over 21 meters long 15
meters across
and weighs over 12 000 tons if you think
about it that's smaller in size than
atlas but it's actually heavier 12 000
tons versus only 7 000 tons that's
because cms really is much more densely
packed
the muon detector in atlas is mostly
empty space it's these big rings that
make it so photogenic whereas cms is
more or less solid metal throughout
including the muon detector
cms because it was literally smaller
lost the drawing to be way on the other
side of the ring the atlas detector has
a location right next to the main cern
campus cms is all the way on the other
side in a little town called sassy in
france and if you go to wikipedia to
look up the city of ceci it was clearly
a wikipedia article written by
physicists working at cms it will tell
you things like this pizza place serves
really really good food but don't go
there if you have a meeting in the
afternoon because they take a long time
to serve you
the spokespeople for cms we have a list
of spokespeople just like for atlas the
first one was a guy named michelle de la
negra from france the second one was
teshender verdi who's a uk physicist who
was born in kenya
then there was guido tonelli from italy
and finally today it's joe incandela
from the united states even though
they're an observer state they're still
full partners in the experiment and it
was joe and candela who was the
spokesperson when the higgs was
discovered i like to list these names
not only to emphasize that physics is a
human endeavor but to show you there are
many different countries making
absolutely central contributions to
making the physics that comes out of the
lhc
in addition to these two major
experiments atlas and cms that look for
everything they can find there are the
dedicated experiments one called alice
and one called lhcb
alice stands for a large ion collider
experiment i told you the acronyms were
not that colorful what alice is doing is
looking not at protons colliding but at
lead ions remember we said that when we
went down the list of all the things you
could accelerate we found that not only
could you accelerate individual
elementary particles but also the nuclei
of atoms
so for one or two months a year the lhc
stops accelerating protons it puts the
protons away and it puts the nuclei of
lead atoms into the accelerator and
accelerates them around the difference
is when lead atoms smash together when
the lead nuclei smash together you get a
tremendous mess
if you were looking for a new particle
like the higgs boson that would be bad
you don't want a mess you want something
clean that you can analyze
but at alice we're intentionally making
a mess because we want to make a plasma
by colliding together these tremendous
collections of protons and neutrons we
create the quark gluon plasma that was
basically what the early universe was
like
alice is literally recreating the
conditions that we had in the big bang
it's not a good way to look for new
particles but it is a good way to
understand the physics underlying the
interactions of many many quarks and
gluons
finally we have lhc b where lhc stands
for large hadron collider and b stands
for beauty what the lhcb detector is
looking for is cp violation using bottom
or beauty quarks so what is cp violation
c is charge conjugation that's the
symmetry or at least the transformation
that exchanges particles for
antiparticles so a c
transformation takes an electron to a
positron and vice versa it leaves a
photon unchanged because photons are
their own antiparticles and of course p
is parity which we know that is violated
in the weak interactions
so
the weak interactions violate parity but
they come very very close to conserving
the combination of parity and charge
conjugation that's called cp
so what do i mean by that i mean that
the fact that the weak interactions
violate parity means that the weak
interactions only couple to left-handed
fermions not to right-handed fermions
that is to say the particles moving
toward you the weak interactions
couple to particles that are rotating
clockwise if they're coming toward you
but not particles that are rotating
counterclockwise if they're coming
toward you however that's for fermions
for anti-fermions it's the other way
around
for anti-fermions the weak interactions
only coupled to right-handed particles
not to left-handed particles so even
though the weak interactions violate
parity because they couple the
left-handed fermions not right-handed
ones if you do parity switching left
with right and charge conjugation
switching fermions with anti-fermions
you get back to where you started as far
as the weak interactions are concerned
so cp is almost conserved by the weak
interactions but not quite
two physicists named james cronin and
val fitch discovered that there's a tiny
amount of cp violation in the standard
model of particle physics and they won
the nobel prize for that
these days we know there's a tiny amount
of cp violation but we also know
that if there are new particles if
they're particles we have not yet
detected
those new particles could very easily
increase the amount of cp violation we
could observe so
if you're looking for new particles for
new physics the most direct way of doing
it is just to make them make the new
particles and watch them decay into
something that's how we discovered the
higgs but there's also an indirect way
to do it remember when we talked about
feynman diagrams we had virtual
particles and loops and there's all
these little particle lines that could
appear inside
a diagram but not on the edges not on
the ones that actually escaped to see to
be visible in the real world so if there
was some tiny little particle that
exerted an influence but only inside the
finemen diagram that could increase the
amount of cp violation if we measured
that it would be evidence for new
physics from a completely different
method that's why at a place like the
lhc you want to have many different
experiments because we want to look for
new physics every single way we can
so that's the lhc that we have we have
two beams going in opposite directions
colliding and being detected at
detectors so that's the design let's go
build it
as you might expect it's the largest
machine ever built there were challenges
during construction for example
because cms
is located on the far side of the ring
far away from the home base of cern
you actually have to move the pieces of
detector that you've built all the way
across the ring so you move them on the
surface which sounds fine just put them
on a truck and take them down the road
except this particular part of france
and switzerland that you're driving
through is full of tiny little medieval
villages very small streets
parts of the detector had to be designed
keeping in mind that they need to fit in
between the buildings on the roads of
these streets it's this kind of
practical challenge that they don't
teach you about in graduate school
then you have to dig the tunnel you have
the tunnel was already there we have to
dig a hole to lower the detector and
lower all the magnets down into the
tunnel so you can actually construct the
lhc ring and the individual detectors
of course when you do this when you
start digging down deep you can be
surprised
it turns out when they were digging the
hole in which they were going to put the
cms detector they found an ancient roman
ruin they found a village from the 4th
century a.d that had jewelry and coins
from the roman empire from as far away
as london
so sadly for physics they kicked out all
the physicists and the engineers and
they brought in the archaeologists the
whole project was delayed for six months
while archaeologists went through this
wonderful new discovery they had made
and it really is quite fascinating
despite the fact that it was delaying
the physics the streets of the village
from the 4th century a.d are actually
parallel to the streets of the same
farms and villages in the same region
today
through the centuries the streets sort
of maintained their structure which is a
fascinating little bit of history that
we wouldn't have known about if we
hadn't built the lhc
so
you do this for a long time remember
1984 was when we started imagining
building the lhc
1993 was when construction really
started in earnest it was september 10th
2008 that it finally turned on
i remember very very vividly because the
whole physics world was very excited
about the lhc starting it was starting
in the morning geneva time which worked
out to midnight california time but
there were news crews that were visiting
caltech and we had a little party we had
pizza and popcorn that we were giving
the tv reporters they all wanted to know
what the big excitement was about about
the large hadron collider i remember the
reporter hal eisner was holding up a
piece of popcorn in front of me on
camera and was saying if it weren't for
the higgs boson would this popcorn
explode
and you know in some sense it would
without the higgs boson the electrons
that hold together the atoms in that
popcorn would fly away at the speed of
light but it's not really the message i
wanted to send about what the lhc was
doing
so september 10th it worked the lac
turned on protons moved around the beams
champagne was popped people had a good
time september 19th nine days later it
exploded
not the whole lhc not the whole 27
kilometer ring but there was a part of
the machine that basically blew up if
you had read the press releases from
cern on september 19th or 20th they
would say they had a little bit of a
leak but it was actually much worse than
that six tons of liquid helium were
splashed across the floor all of the
control room computers lit up with
bright red lynn evans the boss of the
lhc described it as carnage he had never
seen something that was that bad
what had happened is something called a
quench
remember in those super conducting
magnets you want to keep them cold
so they will be superconducting because
if they are not superconducting they
heat up
so you imagine there is a danger here if
just by some random fluctuation the
magnet heats up a little bit
it stops becoming super conducting and
then it heats up more so it runs away
that's exactly what happened that's what
we call a quench one of the magnets was
not made perfectly well it basically
blew up and the problems spread to the
magnets nearby fortunately there was
nobody standing nearby it certainly
would have been a fatal accident that
had happened
so this was very depressing in september
2008 but to their enormous credit
all the physicists who had devoted their
lives to building the lhc picked
themselves up and got right back to work
it took over a year
to fix things but in november 2009 the
lhc came roaring back to life
they only went to half of the design
energy the first lhc run had a total
energy of 7 trillion electron volts not
the 14 they were aiming for
just because they're being cautious but
nevertheless it has been working
enormously well since that date since
november 2009 the lhc has been going
great guns
it wasn't always
perfectly smooth there was a famous
incident
in november 2009 just as they were ready
to start up when there was a power
outage they eventually traced the power
outage to a little piece of baguette a
little piece of french bread that had
fallen into a power station they think
that a pigeon was trying to carry around
its piece of bread and it dropped it as
it was flying over
so the telegraph a newspaper in the
united kingdom had a front page picture
of the large hadron collider and a
pigeon
and the subtitle was large hadron
collider on the left and its arts
nemesis on the right but that was only a
blip on the radar that's the kind of
thing that happens all the time people
were more nervous than usual but it was
fixed almost right away and again since
2009 the lhc has been going great guns
it's very very important that the run be
smooth when you're colliding these
protons together most of the time the
interaction that you get is not going to
be interesting it's just going to be
another example of standard model
physics if you want to discover new
particles you have to have many many
many collisions that's the luminosity we
talked about you'd have as many
collisions as you can possibly collect
together in as short a time as you can
possibly collect together
and that's exactly what we've had if you
imagine plotting the number of
collisions the lhc has witnessed there's
enormously more in 2011 than there was
in 2010 and enormously more again in
2012 compared to 2011. the lhc since
it's been running has been doing a
bang-up job they were running at 7
trillion electron volts for a long time
then in 2012 they got a little bit
cheeky they went up to 8 trillion
electron volts that was exactly what was
needed to finally discover the higgs
boson at the end of that run they
discovered the higgs in july 2012 they
announced the discovery they couldn't
help themselves but run for a few more
months because they had a new toy to
play with they wanted to study the higgs
as well as they could
but at the end of 2012 they shut down
and throughout 2013 and 2014 the lhc was
not running
it's basically that they wanted to
upgrade it they turned it off they went
in there with their soldering irons and
their screwdrivers they're fixing
everything they've learned a lot about
how it works
when it comes back on in 2015 the lac
has been going is going to go at its
design energy it's going to be hitting
that 14 trillion electron volts we're
hoping that that extra energy is exactly
what we need to discover particles
beyond the higgs boson beyond the
standard model of particle physics
[Music]
do
[Music]
you